The Joe Rogan Experience but you know
bees live a very short lifespan so
sometimes they'll just
live out the rest of their bee life and
the bees that we see out in the world
foraging they're at the end of their
their short bee life how long is a bee's
life so a worker bee and we're talking
about honeybees Western honeybees the
ones you see me keep
um
the lifespan of a female worker bee
varies throughout the year so in the
spring and summer when the bees are
working their hardest the female worker
bees will only live about six weeks
in the winter when they're not doing
quite as much and when we need more bees
to make it through the winter they'll
live a little bit longer and they'll
live about six months and their bodies
actually change in the winter the bees
that are born later in the year and need
to make it through the winter will have
more fat bodies on them so that they can
make it through the dearth when there's
nothing in bloom and when bees are
living off the honey that they collected
or stored in their hive earlier in the
year and how long does the Queen live
the queen can live the longest she can
live about five years that's on the
longer end most Queens will live a
little bit shorter but a she can live
significantly longer than all the other
bees in the hive and then we have the
worker bees
um who live about six weeks six months
the queen bee can live up to five years
and the drone bees will live about six
months the male bees and what is the
ratio of male bees to female bees
they're a honeybee colony is about 95
female and the amount of male bees can
actually fluctuate throughout the year
so when we need male bees around to mate
with a queen and they'll mate with a
queen not their Queen but when we need
more male bees around the colony will
produce more male bees in the winter
when there aren't as many resources
available to the bees
the female bees will kick all the male
bees out of the hive and they'll either
starve or freeze to death
so right now there are no male bees and
in most hives
um the in these bees that came along
with me today there's there's not a
single male honeybee there they starved
it down they starve to death they have
no way of foraging they don't do the
work of bees so most people have never
seen a male honeybee before and that's
just because male honeybees don't are
out in the world doing the work of bees
they stay in the hive or they leave and
they go to drone congregation areas to
mate with a queen but you know they're
not going to be on a flower or in your
wine glass or whatnot so the male bees
don't mate with their own females would
that be like mating with the mother that
would be like incestuous right so so
here's what happens within the colony
when it's time to for the queen bee to
mate so once a queen bee is born when
she reaches the ripe age of about seven
days old she'll go on a mating flight
and she may go on only one possibly two
mating flights in her entire life
and she'll fly out of the hive and
she'll go to a drone congregation area
which is exactly what it sounds like
it's an area where there's a bunch of
drone male honeybees flying around just
waiting for a queen bee to fly by and
these drone congregation areas exist
about a hundred feet in the sky which is
another reason you would never see a
male honeybee but
if a queen bee flies by
fastest strongest drones win and they
will successfully mate with a queen and
the queen will meet with only about 15
to 20 drone bees and she'll have enough
sperm to last the rest of her life
and what happens to the male bees is
once they mate with a queen their
endophallus rips out of their abdominal
cavity and they fall to the ground and
that's the end of their little bee life
whoa so they died during mating they die
during mating harsh life for a male bee
look at it I guess die when you have sex
yes I mean but also you know his his
genes pass on and he's and he's a
successful male honeybee so but they
also don't have to do a lot of work in
the hive you know they they don't forage
for food they don't build the hive they
don't have wax glands they don't even
have stingers they don't defend the hive
so they have one rule so how does the
the does the males know is it there a
specific time of the year where the
males know that the female Queen is
going to be flying around sure in the
spring and in the summer and that's when
you know that's their only job so if
they're present that's what they're
trying to do and that's why the colony
controls how many drones there are so
right now in the hive there aren't that
many drone bees because
they're trying to conserve the resources
they have so the honey that we eat from
bees is their food source in the winter
when nothing is In Bloom and there's no
four there's no flowers out there for
them to forage from wow so when what
what are they they're the male bees when
they're inside the hive what what's
their specific job like what kind of
work are they doing when they're in
there they're really not doing a lot of
work just hanging out eating there's
some research will show that they're you
know contributing to the heating of the
hive but they're really not doing a lot
of work even when you see them in the
colony you know not only can you
distinguish them because they look
different from the female female worker
bees they're larger than the female
worker bees but they're not doing
anything they're they're walking around
different you know they're kind of
fumbling and bumbling around so they
really don't have a lot of a lot of
purpose and which is why there aren't
that many of them you know we have to
keep in mind they only make up about 5
percent of the population maybe 10
sometimes zero so there aren't that many
male honeybees and I always love sharing
with people that they probably have
never seen one so if you're ever near an
observation Hive or have the opportunity
to go into a hive with a beekeeper you
know I encourage folks to do that and
make sure you ask to see a see a male
honeybee so they fly up in the air and
they put a fur moment out that lets the
queen know that they're there yes
they'll put a drone the drones will emit
a pheromone and you know the and these
drone congregation areas still remain
somewhat of a mystery they seem to be a
place that the drones will go back to
annually but we don't really know
why or how they select these areas
there's some research that shows you
know they're covered by wind they're
going to be a safe area for this for the
bees to fly around but
um and they're massive they're they can
be a hundred feet in the sky but they
can be about 500 feet wide I mean a ton
of male honeybees flying around just
doing circles waiting for a queen to fly
by and how does the queen detect where
they are like in terms of like
pheromones I think it's just the
chemical pheromones you know and they're
they're going and they're not flying
that far from their hive area so um you
know it's within a radius bees to forage
will only fly about two miles so um but
you know it's a they go every day this
is the males the drones fly out of the
hive and try to do this try to mate
successfully every day so they're always
doing this and most drones will never
meet with a queen you know it's a small
percentage of drones that mate with a
queen because she only mates with maybe
15 to 20 drones so do bees have a nose
like we think of a nose is it they in
you know their world very much exists
through sense but it's not they don't
really have a nose like we do you know
they even have
um they can taste through their feet
they even have a way to taste the
difference between sweet and salty
through their feet and I believe it's
just glands that they're doing this
through but you know they have antennae
too which their antennae help them you
know move within the colony and talk to
each other and clean themselves
but uh yeah they're remarkable Little
Creatures there's it's so fascinating
how they have this uniform structure The
Hive yes with all these little catacombs
and all these little Combs that they
create and they all do it the same way
yes like how do they know how to do it
do we have an understanding of how they
teach each other or is it innate in
their genetics like well the cone
building is a really interesting
um is a really interesting process
because we see it as hexagonal comb
right we see little hexagons within the
hive but they actually start off
building it as circles so the weight of
the hive will will bring it down in the
way that they build the comb is actually
up at an angle so that the honey doesn't
seep out it's remarkable what they
have figured out how to do as a species
how to engineer
this perfect building
and do it out of beeswax out of
something that their body produces
naturally I mean I can think of no
better example that nature has given us
for a sustainable creature that can
build its home out of you know something
that comes off of its body and just
live with what's around with what's
around them and then always leave the
world better than they found it it's
they're amazing it is very fascinating
but do we have any sort of studies on
what what is the process that's going on
within them that allows them to know
when it's time to create these Combs and
I don't know if it's when it's time to
create the Combs I mean they need they
start creating a comb as soon as they
find a cavity to build in most of the
comb building takes place within the
first 40 days the bees will build the
majority of their hives so it's I would
I don't know for sure but I would say
it's just a natural instinct when they
find a place to live they need
safety and they need a place to break to
bring up their young the queen lays eggs
in the comb it's not just storing honey
and food you know this is where the bees
also raise their young and I think it's
just they know that they need a safe
place to live and so they start to build
a beehive immediately and does the if
the queen it's it's a solitary Queen in
in the hive in the colony so what
happens when females are born so the
female bees are the worker bees and
they're the ones that make up about you
know 95 of the population and they
cannot lay eggs that have been
fertilized so they can lay eggs that
only result in drone male bees so
there's no competition between the queen
and the worker bees I mean there's you
know the queen has one job that's to lay
eggs for the colony she is essentially
the female reproductive organ of this
greater being that is the superorganism
of a bee Colony so when the worker bees
are born they're they're the ones doing
all the work for the hive those the
other female bees besides the queen bee
so the does the queen when the worker
bees are born and you said they lay eggs
and they can only make males they don't
lay eggs so they can and on occasion
they will if a colony is queenless but
it doesn't mean the colony can continue
so without a queen a colony can't
continue so as a last resort is the only
time you will see female worker bees
laying eggs in a colony and they will
lay eggs that turn into bees that look
different they're male drone bees and so
they're they're larvae and their pupae
look a little bit different than the
worker bees and so as a beekeeper if you
see a colony full of male honeybee
babies brewed eggs and larvae
it's a sign that a colony may be without
a queen and what happens then so as a
beekeeper you can
introduce a new Queen to the Colony and
likely they'll accept her you can also
give the colony eggs from another Colony
that are female eggs so female bee eggs
any female bee egg can be made into a
queen bee so if you give a colony that's
queenless the opportunity to make their
own Queen that's sometimes even better
than introducing a new Queen to them and
the way that a queen bee is made is when
the queen bee lays an egg and if it's a
female worker B egg which most of them
are because again 95 of the colonies
population is female
every bee in the first three days of
their life they're fed royal jelly and
then they're switched to a diet of
pollen and a little bit of nectar but if
a baby bee is fed royal jelly through
the duration of its development
it turns into a queen bee
but a regular worker bee cannot give
birth or cannot lay an egg that would be
a queen bee or even a female being
correct so where does that female become
from only from a queen
where does yes so a queen can only give
birth to a queen
a queen can lay both female and male ba
I shouldn't say give birth so a female
can lay a female Just So does when a
female when a queen knows that her time
is short when she's about to die does
she like make a successor well it's not
always the queen that knows and it's
more The Colony that's making the
decision so we often think of you know a
colony of bees being a monarchy where
the queen is in charge and making all of
the decisions but
that's not the case at all it's the
colony making the decisions so it's all
the worker bees it's the collective of
female worker bees making that decision
and they can take any female egg and
turn it into a queen bee not only by
that diet of royal jelly but they will
also make the cell that the bee is born
into a little bit bigger to accommodate
the queen bee's larger body size so it's
actually the group of female worker bees
that's making that decision and the
queen bee doesn't always know when she's
in her final days it's the colony that
would know her pheromones would get
weaker and they would prepare for having
a new Queen and sometimes even have a
new Queen develop while their old Queen
is still alive and in the case that you
have a colony with an older Queen who is
failing and a new Queen who was just who
just emerged from a cell
the Queens will fight to the death oh
Jesus and the in the best Queen wins and
that's you know that's what happened
that's what needs to happen for the life
of the bee colony
wow they fight to the death
what a ruthless world